and somehow within minutes of this
happening the new york times knows
what i'm holding in my hand they know
the subject of the secret grand jury
subpoena how the hell do they know that
of course
the new york times is talking to
coordinating with working with the fbi
and that's why i wrote this book what
because i know this sounds crazy it
sounds like science fiction it's not
science fiction this is my life this is
real this is truth this is the reality
and you need to understand the reality
you're living in
the new york times
and the fbi
are working together
in a world when
journalists are supposed to speak truth
to power they're representing the power
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 135
featuring project veritas ceo and
founder james o'keefe james is a
self-described guerrilla journalist who
organizes and performs undercover
investigations to expose corruption in
both the public and private sectors
he's involved in a lot of scandals
mostly with democrats
twitter suspended his account in april
last year but have since let him join
back you can't tag him on instagram
either
undeterred
james has a new book american muckraker
which describes some of the resignations
arrests and fbi raids he's been involved
in since the birth of project veritas
james is definitely a muckraker
i hope you enjoy this episode if you do
please consider subscribing
before we get started i have a cyber
security question for you do you ever
use facebook to log in somewhere else
what if someone somehow gained access
hackers would get a free shot at all
linked accounts which is terrifying
given how many accounts use facebook to
log into
the outcomes of that could be
harmless
or could go to full-blown identity theft
thankfully we have nor to pass that's
what i use nordpass keeps all your notes
and passwords in a single incredibly
secure location only you can access with
the master password it also monitors
password health and data breaches like
facebook and linkedin had last year so
you'll know before anything bad happens
put your mind at ease online with
nordpass visit nordpass.com tmpp like
the michaela peterson podcast acronym or
use code tmpp for 50 off two years plus
a free month of nordpass premium with a
30-day money-back guarantee
only available until february 10th
at nordpass.com
tmpp use code tnpp i hope you enjoyed
this episode
[Music]
james o'keefe welcome to my podcast
great to be here thank you so much for
coming to nashville and seeing me in
person this is amazing yeah this is
great well you're here to discuss
this
american muckraker
that's right
but before we get started probably for
anyone who doesn't know who you are can
you give a brief background about who
you are and what it is you do
well um i'm the founder of a group
called project veritas and what we do is
we're
a group of investigative journalists
we've been around for about 12 years and
we go around usually undercover catching
people in the act doing waste fraud
abuse corruption
and recently our model has shifted to
whistleblowing so people on the inside
of these institutions come to us usually
with documents or recordings
proof of fraud or abuse or lying or
hypocrisy
we used to go undercover to try to get
on the inside but now there's just a lot
of these people on the inside that come
to us they come to our tip line and we
then send our undercover people out to
corroborate what they've found
uh and we've done stories and you name
it we've done stories on it and you name
the institution we probably have people
inside that institution trying to blow
the whistle our tagline is be brave do
something and we try to encourage people
to
not be afraid
that
is crazy like how did you get started
doing that kind of thing
well it's kind of a long story but in a
nutshell i
i'm 37 um
i when i was a teenager
i went to college in new jersey i'm from
new jersey and um
i i
remember at a relatively young age i
looked at the media and i was reading
the new york times every day front to
back
and i
felt there was something off about the
way the information was presented
uh
things were not as they seemed and often
rarely as they should be
i didn't know what to do about it but i
went to college and i was surrounded by
professors who were
avowedly
communist and it kind of i guess they
could radicalize me a bit
political correctness i was really
outraged by so i decided to
do this sort of stunt journalism
and i was pretty shy at the time i was
like 19 years old and i decided to
ban lucky charms on the grounds they're
racist against my irish heritage
i did so as a form of satire
like sort of borat meets 60 minutes
but they took me seriously this is in
2004. now irony is a little dead these
days but at the time it was funny and
the and the dean of the university took
it seriously and told me that they would
indeed remove lucky charms this is the
first sort of hidden what year what year
was this
actually st patrick's day 2005. okay
yeah
so that was the the genesis of this
technique of exposing them for who they
are
getting them on videotape
being who they are therefore
no explanation is required it just makes
sense to the viewer and that's what we
try to do at veritas it's cinema verite
it's direct you don't have to trust my
interpretation of the events you just
show people the reality
okay
so have you been have you been censored
at all has because if what you're doing
is going out and trying to expose the
truth so you're just it's all vid video
footage
yeah has that been censored on any
platform oh yeah we're we're removed on
twitter i'm banned on twitter uh project
veritas is banned on twitter you can't
tag me on instagram it says i've been
spreading quote false information about
kovid but the thing about that that's
interesting is that the the anything
we've broken on cover the last few
months
has been pfizer executives speaking out
of their own mouths
i didn't make these statements we quoted
a pfizer executive saying
that your antibodies are stronger than
their own vaccine that was a pfizer
scientist on hidden camera
we broke a story from vanessa gelman a
director at pfizer pharmaceutical
saying
you should not tell people about fetal
cells human fetal cells used in the
development of the vaccine so we report
on what these people are saying and they
ban me
for quoting them i don't know why
they're not banning
people making these statements yeah so
we're censored but it really hasn't
stopped us
the story we did last week uh on darpa
uh
documents inside the defense department
was trending number one on twitter even
though we were banned okay um i want to
get into that actually what is darpa i'm
so not
like well versed in in this kind of
information so what does darpa stand for
uh defense advanced
research
projects agency
and they're a division of the department
of defense okay in arlington virginia
washington dc and
this was a document
veritas released last week from a source
and the document stated was written by a
marine corps major commandant fellow at
the defense department so very serious
people
and the marine corps major argued in
this document which was buried in a
top secret share drive
we obtained this document michaela and
the document stated that
there was gain of function research in
march of 2018
this group eco health alliance
approached the department of defense
and and uh and the department of defense
rejected the gain of research proposal
because it was too risky
so what is what is gain of function gain
of function is uh research done on covid
on bat
born coronaviruses to do research on
this thing to develop this
uh covid uh
military applications national security
applications the department of defense
rejected this proposal on the grounds it
was not safe that's good
that's a good thing
but the document also states that
dr anthony fauci
uh proceeded with the research
through
niaid
if that's true
if what this marine corps guy is saying
inside the defense department is true
then anthony fauci lied
in congress
so last week dr fauci brought up this
these documents in a senate hearing and
and uh he brought them up he brought
them up okay he brought up project
veritas in his weird new york accent
there he does
he brought him up and he appeared to
authenticate the documents but he
questioned
what the marine corps was saying major
was saying
okay a lot to unpack here
yeah so did he suggest that
so the documents were real but the
what the
was lying right he what he said was
something to the effect of i have not
seen that proposal from
uh to darpa
but the eco-health alliance proposal to
darpa may have been different
than the eco-health alliance proposal to
niaid
so i think he was probably playing a
semantics game there
and what we want anthony fauci to do is
release these documents the public has a
right to know at this point and if
anthony found she does not release the
document then there's a good chance that
an organization like project veritas
might release the document visa via
whistleblower
wow
just like the one that was just released
these are not these documents are not
authorized to be released
and if you do a foia request this
information is often redacted
and this is really belies the mission of
what we're trying to accomplish
we think that
government is in an advanced state of
sclerosis
where
there's no
you can't legislate judges can't solve
these problems you can't you can't get
foia requests to get the documents you
need whistleblowers you need people on
the inside
who are brave enough to
jump on a
metaphorical grenade and give up their
livelihood for the public's right to
know and there's really not many places
where those people can go but they can
go to project veritas
that's wild
do you think any of these documents that
you're potentially exposing put the
american government at risk
no
i think you have to make an editorial
decision on a case-by-case basis but
because
i don't know how 5.4 million people have
died and many more people suffer as a
result of this
i think the public has a right to know
and i think you always have to do
there's this chapter in this book called
privacy
um
i had a conversation with another
podcast eric weinstein who you may know
and he him and i went on it for two
hours
and his criticism of me was james you
harm people your journalism harms people
and what i told eric which is the same
thing i'll tell you is that
in a society like the united states of
america where you place a primary value
on the public's right to know
your your journalism is always going to
harm people
but there has to be a balancing test
between
uh
the value of the information versus the
harm done to the individual in this case
it's a no-brainer this is a
epidemic that's killed people and we
need to know the origins of it
okay i think that's reasonable
i think that's completely reasonable
what was what was eric saying was
damaging it was it that in particular
well
i don't think eric was making a whole
lot of sense in his argument and i told
him that you can go watch it on youtube
it's he he had this whole he's a
mathematical genius so he made this
whole analogy i wasn't on the efficiency
frontier in other words i should blur
people's faces more often
and i told them well if i did that
then people would question the
credibility of the material
and uh
and i disagree i think in order to go
after the institution you have to expose
the individual you have to put a name
and a face on it
and i also told eric that
we we do record people without them
knowing and some people think that's
unethical you know no one wants to be
recorded without them knowing yeah
but the difference is whenever we do
that we're always with the person i
would never
bug someone or
record you when you're completely alone
and we would make the argument that the
recording device is an extension of the
right to speak
because if i write down what you say
it's not going to be as accurate as if i
recorded you so we believe that
recording someone so long as you're with
them it's basically a constitutional
right
it's a human right okay i can see how
that could get i can see how people
would argue against that
but
depending on what you're using that for
and especially if it has to do with
covid then
that seems like a necessity at this
point
how is this
kind of job okay so how long have you
been doing this you said you kind of got
started in journalism when you were
19
which seems kind of early for picking up
on the politically correct
universities 20 2005. yeah this is this
is early when i started the centurion at
rutgers it was
before facebook i mean i think facebook
was november 2004 and i remember i was
laying out the newspaper in the summer
of 2004 was before twitter before
youtube
was very early
and um wow i
would do the new jersey equivalent of a
public information request into all my
professors salaries so i
this is like the worst student well
i did i didn't get my classes get in the
way of my education let's say that way
i i remember
going into the public records office and
they just had the information i just
scanned it and published it and and i
would put the newspaper in the um
po box for all the professors it's like
muckraking
you know transparency and it was very
uncomfortable thing for me to do
um but i felt it necessary i then i
started confronting professors with a
video camera
i did that
you know in college and then i graduated
from college and i proceeded to do it on
a bigger scale planned parenthood
did some work with lila rose who's an
activist i and then i did a story on
acorn
which was uh i'm not familiar with acorn
gov organization that gets money from
the government to
deal with foreclosure homes and voter
registration drives and i went into
acorn as a pimp i dressed up like a pimp
and i got a 20 year old girl to be my
she was playing the role of a prostitute
and we went to acorn saying we wanted to
start an underage prostitution business
it was like a sting operation what this
is about 11 years ago
and it was a big story uh the videos
caused acorn to be defunded in congress
as a result of this these videos and
that was really what
that really got veritas on the map and
led me to do many more stories like that
that's that's wild wow
have you ever taken any personality
tests just like side note uh
i've taken one called disc have you
heard of that i haven't heard of ifc no
i'm pretty like my dad has one so um
what is that called it's called it's
understand myself but it's the it does
the big five so it it judges how
agreeable you are or how neurotic you
are you don't strike me as somebody very
agreeable and or very nervous how would
you characterize what is your first
impression well you might you have to be
unbelievably disagreeable in order to do
the kind of work you do right like most
people would
be more concerned about i think the
feelings of other people and you look
like you're more concerned with what the
information that's out there and the
truth right yes
and then neuroticism that's just like
how likely you are to experience
negative emotion and anxiety
and i don't think you'd be able to do
what you're doing if you were a neurotic
person interesting i never i never
thought about
the neurosis i do think
there's a chapter in this book called
character and i try to identify
the qualities of someone in this day and
age who
could do this sort of journalism speak
truth to power and
the new york times used to say do the
journalism without fear or favor what
does that mean well
without fear without favor you're not
chasing after rewards you're not you're
not doing this for
some type of financial gain
um
uh
so
i
i've done a lot of introspection and i
did talk to a psychologist and i said
help me understand myself like what what
because everyone
comments you should they're so if
everyone's so afraid all the comments
are
you do you have security and i don't
really think about that i don't i don't
i do have security but i don't worry
about it
and i think it has to do with the fact
that
i'm not we're not really political
people but we're branded as such you
know
i think political people
the essence of it is you want to do harm
to those who are on the other side of
you and that's really not our mission
i also think you have to have a degree
of tunnel vision i don't know if how
that compares with neurosis but you have
to be extremely tunnel vision nothing
can get in your way
you have to be indefatigable
laura logan who's another journalist i
deeply respect and admire
i was talking to her about some of the
things that we've been through and she
said well those things are great for you
because those are those are what get the
sources to trust you
so when you do go through this pain and
you get arrested and sued and
you you keep going you're effectively
getting the people inside the government
to to trust you enough to come to you in
the first place so it's kind of all
accumulated that's actually a really
good point yeah because if you'd yeah
that makes sense
okay well how has this been um i know i
heard of something about an fbi raid yes
when they banged on my door i knew that
it was the authorities because they had
just raided two of my former colleagues
two days
previous
so my first thought
as this banging and i woke up was
how long have they been banging on my
door because i knew within a matter of
seconds they were going to break the
door
so this is what's going through my head
in an fbi raid i i sprinted towards the
door so that they wouldn't break the
door
and i went to open the door and i put my
hand on the doorknob and i'm saying i'm
opening the door now because this is
like a movie i mean they're like fbi
open up just just just like you would
think it would be
and and i think i think like shoot me
when i open my door
so i open the door and there's this like
close encounters of the third kind
bright white lights in my face i can't
see anything it's pitch black 601 am
uh on a saturday morning in in new york
so they turned me around and handcuffed
me and they and i'm in my boxer briefs
and they put me
in the hallway of my apartment building
my neighbors are obviously at this point
all awake
and uh at first i think am i under
arrest
yeah and if i'm under arrest let me
speak to my attorney but evidently they
had a search warrant
signed by a magistrate judge
which is a lower federal judge in the
southern district of new york
which is a federal jurisdiction new york
state
and then they showed me the search
warrant and it listed a number of crimes
that either there they may think that i
have committed or somebody else may have
committed those crimes include
accessory after the fact
and miss prison of a felony what does
that mean
well and i'm not a lawyer so i'm going
to paraphrase what i think it means
miss prison of a felony is effectively a
bystander law that you know somebody
else has committed a crime but you
didn't do anything about it accessory
after the fact well that's pretty
self-evident that means that you helped
someone
but
i'm a journalist
and
journalists have stolen documents sent
to them all the time i did not know that
this diary was stolen i don't think it
was
currently i don't think it is
but even if it was it's my right
under the constitution to publish it
which i didn't
so that's legal as a journalist you can
be sent things or given things and
published them yeah uh supreme court
case 2001 bart nikki v vapper
establishes the right of a journalist to
publish a document which is stolen so
long as the journalist played no part in
the theft of that document
it's a supreme court i mean i mean it's
kind of
it's kind of common sense imagine
imagine someone sends you something and
it's stolen well you don't know you
can't you can't control whether it was
sent to you
and and so the supreme court has
established this and
and i uh i knew that so i'm holding the
search warrant right and i'm you know
i'm kind of
kind of to be a little vulnerable from
it i'm
i was in a i was in a state of i guess
you could call it ptsd
after this occurred because i had been
uh arrested 10 years prior and i'd been
through this whole federal process it's
the process that is the punishment
oftentimes with these things
and i and i was holding the search
warrant in my hand looking at it as
these agents backed away you know they
sort of back away while they're taking
photographs
and i'm like this is am i dreaming am i
in some type of dostoyevsky
novel i don't know what's going on and
then and then while i'm holding the
search warrant which lists these
chicken [ __ ] charges absurd absurd
ridiculous crimes
they would never charge the new york
times with these crimes because it's
it's laughable
i get a text message from the new york
times
and somehow within minutes of this
happening the new york times knows
what i'm holding in my hand they know
the subject of the secret grand jury
subpoena how the hell do they know that
of course
the new york times is talking to
coordinating with working with the fbi
and that's why i wrote this book what
because i know this sounds crazy it
sounds like science fiction it's not
science fiction this is my life this is
real this is truth this is the reality
and you need to understand the reality
you're living in the new york times
and the fbi
are working together
in a world when
journalists are supposed to speak truth
to power they're representing the power
what was interesting about this episode
is that
while the new york times was working in
concert with the fbi
there were a lot of other journalists
out there who did defend us and you had
a lot of people on the left who were
upset about this
the aclu
defended project veritas what is the
aclu american civil liberties union okay
and
a lot of these organizations were
disagreed with us uh on our stories but
they still came to our defense but this
is truly an extraordinary series of
events it's ongoing
um i have not been charged with anything
and a federal judge in new york uh
ordered the fbi to stop
going through my phone they took my two
cell phones and only
my two cell phones they didn't take my
ipad or my laptop
which is very unusual
this whole thing is yeah that is
extremely unusual yes
so i didn't realize that a judge would
be able to
i mean like i said i'm not very familiar
with the hierarchy of these
organizations but i didn't realize a
federal judge can just tell the fbi to
leave you alone
well the
fbi and the department of justice are
executive branch agencies and they need
judicial they need permission from a
judge to execute a search warrant it's a
very aggressive
move for the fbi to execute a search
warrant
for the fbi to execute stories i mean
they put you in handcuffs they raid your
home they i mean this is a very
intrusive
and highly aggressive move and usually
they don't do this without indicting
someone
but they do need permission from a lower
federal judge so the judge that signed
the search warrant in new york question
is what did why did she sign it what
what what did they present her with to
the justification
and then an article three judge that is
to say
a federal judge for life
a judge named torres in new york
ordered them to stop
going through my phones
and assigned what's called a special
master over the fbi an independent
uh individual independent legal
individual this thing is wild that's
crazy it sounds like a
it sounds like i'm making this up i i'm
not this is all happening it's still
happening i don't know how it's going to
conclude um
but
i think the thing about it is that
there's different rules
if you work for nbc news or cbs or
the new york times
um
then there's another thing that happened
they published my attorney client
privilege documents within days of this
happening my private lawyer memos the
new york times did
that were stolen or obtained illicitly
so how did they get copies of those we
don't know
so this is what happened in the last few
months
that's so that's that reason oh yeah
this happened in november just two three
months ago
wow do you have a family
i have a
mother and a father and a sister yep
okay so you were by yourself when the
fbi came
yeah and uh that's unbelievably
stressful um
but i have a good team we have a good
team at veritas in fact some of them
walked into the studio here there's a
bunch of them and
they're good people and i always say
that i can't i can't continue doing this
without people
beside me who
you know it's it's
it's not easy but uh
it's it's not always so difficult
there's there is great joy in fighting
and
there's just some days that are very
hard
some days and then you get through that
day and put your pants on the next day
and
go back at it
so i probably kind of already touched on
this but why do you continue doing this
if things like things happen like the
fbi raids your house like that is
scary that's like i can i can imagine
you being well like you said concerned
you're gonna get shot
so
why
why keep doing this if
it's ending up being potentially life
and death
i don't think that i'll get shot
[Music]
i think
i think initially when you're so
passionate about something
and you have a vision a very clear
vision of what you want to do and what
you want to accomplish
at a certain point you don't you're so
committed the passion and the desire to
see the thing happen
will overcome whatever marginal fear you
may feel because the excitement
and the fun of it i don't know what it
may be fun is not the right word but the
the desire to see your vision come to
fruition is so motivating
i don't i'm not a psychologist and
frankly i think you probably know more
about that field much more than i do but
speaking personally
you're so passionate about it that
you'll do anything to see it come to
fruition that's the first reason that's
the most important reason for me
the second reason is the responsibility
all these people
in the government that come to you
and they say please don't stop
and they say there's nowhere else for us
to go i mean
these people
you know military people
you know we have sources inside the
department of justice we have people
inside tech and
pinterest and facebook and google and
twitter and
you have a responsibility so you really
can't stop
because those people look up to you but
i would say the for the first most
important
most important reason is the passion
okay and what is it like can you tell me
exactly what it is that you want to see
come to fruition
i think more people coming out exposing
what's really going on
and what what do you think is really
going on like what's underneath
all this well i don't know i mean i
we'll see uh
uh
things are not as things are not as they
seem and
as mike wallace has once said as rarely
as they should be
you know the the world that's presented
to us by our media officials are often
the official sanctioned information
journalism used to be about running
towards the podium asking questions and
now they run
away from the podium towards us with
sanctioned information and if you say
anything contrary to
the orthodoxy that that they'll censor
you
so
my vision is a massive movement of
whistleblowers and insiders who release
the real information
okay and i'm very hopeful most people
are very cynical and hopeless
um
i think that that will happen i think it
is happening but mark my words i know
that that will happen
you don't think something like big tech
is going to take that out
like you release too many of these
too much information on certain
platforms you just delete you off of
that platform no because i i believe
content is king i believe if the
journalism
um
you're canadian right marshall mcluhan
the canadian philosopher didn't he say
something like the image will replace
the politician i'm paraphrasing the
image is so powerful there's a chapter
in this book called image
images transfix
in a way that words do not
so veritas's whole model is video
i don't report anything unless you can
see the people's lips moving
so interesting video we did last week on
the literally the pentagon papers i mean
i don't know if the new york times had
published the pentagon papers these days
literally it wasn't my words it was this
marine corps guy inside the defense
department
and what was remarkable is that not only
michaela did tech not to censor that
video they took it down eventually
but people were like organically
uploading it until it trended number one
on twitter and i'm not even on twitter
so i believe if the story is strong
enough and good enough it'll trend
okay on networks that don't like the
story
okay i think that's probably reasonable
wow well that's a lot okay i've got a
bunch of questions i haven't gotten to
any of them yet
but
i've got a bunch of questions for you
okay let's let's start with this
um
well i mean we kind of covered this with
the fbi but have you been threatened for
uncovering things personally
in what way
well i guess like anyway
letters people showing up
misinformation put out about you oh yeah
i mean
that
the the way they usually
threaten or or or intimidate you is
through the legal process
lawsuits and litigation
is that like going into people's
personal lives and getting sued for
doing that or is it just random threats
like what happened with the fbi
initially
there's a whole chapter in this book
called litigation and i talk about
they've sued us so many times we've
never lost a lawsuit they use the
lawsuit as a as a vehicle to try to
bankrupt you or
uh punish you or expose your emails
through the discovery process of
litigation and
in the evolution of my doing this i i
quickly realized that
that will only work so long as you do
something wrong in private
anything we do is going to come out
right there
if i you i can't keep secrets
so in the discovery process of a lawsuit
they obtain my emails if it's relevant
to the lawsuit and if i write something
in the email that i don't want people to
see they'll find it
so i had i learned
through this process of litigation that
they the people that want to shut us
down they do keep secrets
they don't want to be sued
they stopped suing us
when they realized oh i could i could
when we do discovery i can propose you
to i can get your emails and then they
realize oh i thought o'keefe was going
to fold and give us a settlement
we don't settle lawsuits
and sometimes that means we have to
spend a million bucks or two million
bucks to get to a jury trial
and i could have made it go away for a
hundred thousand dollars
so i think that the number one
is it a threat it's a it's a form of
it's a form of coercion intimidation and
an attempt to silence you and break your
will it's always the courts it's always
um
the system of
justice the system of injustice that's
how they've primarily
done this
in 2010 i was arrested in a federal
building in new orleans louisiana
for trying to investigate a
senator
i walked in off the street in plain
clothes showed my real id it's an open
building to the public and they arrested
me and when they found out who i was
they charged me with a crime i didn't
commit
it was a ten year felony
what yeah ten years for trying to
destroy federal property interfere with
a telephone system
i wrote another book about that it's
called breakthrough
and
you you know as a young 25 year old
idealistic naive
sort of bushy-tailed
young man and
i was complete i mean it was
traumatizing i was putting shackles
federal shackles in an orange jumpsuit
my mug shot made the front page of the
new york times on sunday above the fold
and they made me out to be a i was
trying to bomb a federal building with
my iphone it was
ridiculous
wow
how long did how how long were you
wrapped up in that for three and a half
years on federal probation i was
arraigned i was put in the parish jail
in new orleans
so when you say
uh and i could we could talk about that
for 30 minutes i won't you can go out
and read the story go online and read
about it
my point is
so far
thank god there has never been any
violence or any any you know sort of
those sorts of threats i think people
are unless you're a lunatic you're
afraid i'm going to expose you with your
plot to commit these things yeah
they put you in shackles and put you in
jail
that'll deter people
and the whole point and the whole point
is some people
well the whole point is they want to
deter other people from following in our
footsteps
but if you keep going
you send a message to those people that
they can do it too
if you keep going
you're going to inspire in fact more
people than if you had not gone through
that to begin with
and i thank those prosecutors in new
orleans every day
and it's they're the ones who are
suffering they all got disbarred by the
way lost their law licenses
that's another thing i've learned the
world is round
that bad people do bad things and get
away with it but not forever
not forever especially when there's an
army of whistleblowers out there
watching and waiting with hidden cameras
okay what's the what's the like what are
the top worst things you've uncovered
like have you ever uncovered anything
that have you ever gone down a rabbit
trail that
you
you didn't know at all where it was
going to lead to and you were shocked at
what you discovered
i want to hear some of those stories
interesting um or did you always have
some sort of idea like uh even with
covid i mean there were kind of quite a
few people talking about whether or not
it was you know what were the origins
and
so
has anything been like absolutely
shocking
well
i'm thinking we've done a lot of things
i think
um
[Music]
i'm not shocked often times
you try to confirm suspicions you have a
suspicion or a hypothesis for example
uh antibodies are better than the
vaccine you might have a hypothesis
yeah
so okay let's go out and confirm that so
in that case we actually did launch an
investigation into pfizer and we did
record a pfizer scientist saying those
words
we confirmed the suspicion
that's harder to do as a if you're an
investigative reporter
um the easier thing to do is to
let the source come to you and determine
what the story is because if you have
the hypotheses you could spend years
trying to confirm it and fail
and it's very difficult to get on the
inside of an organization like that you
without running a foul of the law and we
don't break the law
so oftentimes the better thing to do
when it comes to going down a rabbit
hole is have the source come to you
and don't publish it without
corroborating it
you know don't don't try to get a couple
different sources to confirm it uh
another wild thing
um 2016 the 2016 election uh we did a
story on a guy named bob creamer and
scott fobel in chicago and wisconsin
and they were going around to trump
rallies
and they were
bird dogging as they called it they were
inciting violence at these rallies and
blaming it on trump and these people
were on tape admitting to this oh wow
and this guy worked for close to hillary
clinton this is in 2016.
very powerful guy close friends with
barack obama and he said into a hidden
camera don't tell anybody that we're
doing this he literally said those words
and how do you get people in close
enough to these other people
and
then those other people will actually
admit these things like well wouldn't
you
why would you tell someone you weren't
very close with some of these secrets
well that's a good question
and
the bottom line is you have to
build a rapport with someone such that
they trust you wow
undercover work again we don't do this
as much these days because we have
whistleblowers but back when i got
started
undercover work was often about finding
what people's needs were
and a lot of people are motivated by
money
some people are motivated by a sense of
ego they brag
or
they'll brag to a beautiful woman or
they'll some people are motivated by sex
so you're you're trying to figure out
what their need is and meet the needs so
in that particular case bob creamer
needed money
so there was a
donor who had a
niece
and and he confided all of these things
to the
donor's niece in a public place
where it's not illegal to record in a
public cafe wow he was speaking loudly
enough in this cafe where people around
him could hear him
so it's perfectly legal
but he did not know that he would he was
being recorded
wow so when you were doing all this
undercover work who came up with the
like ideas on how to kind of get people
to talk
i think the people that i hire you know
i try to
you know i'm the ceo of the company but
i
these days we've gotten to such a size
where i'm not speaking directly with the
sources i'm trusting the people that i
hire we're training them
we have a pretty rigorous uh
curriculum and
most of it's ethics there's a chapter in
this book called ethics
i talked about that that's interesting
eric weinstein for two hours about
ethics
um actually on on that podcast and it's
you know ethics is a is a tough a tough
thing it's
because it's inherently situational
right
if you're deceiving
if i'm deceiving you in order to extract
or elicit a truth from you
i'm doing that so that i can tell the
truth to the people out there
but if i'm identifying myself as who i
am with you and i'm saying oh by the way
this is being recorded
it's just the law of human nature that
you're less likely to be honest with me
and if you're less and if you're not
honest with me and i'm broadcasting the
dishonesty
i would argue that that's
less that's that's that's the not as
good as if i was deceiving you and
broadcasting the truth to the public so
it's a question of relative deception
and you only have these two options in
journalism
and journalism where journalism have
been corrupted
is that these new york times reporters
washington post reporters cnn whoever
will will say hi i'm from cnn tell me mr
government official tell me what's going
on inside your department it's like give
me a break
they're never going to tell you where
the the secret juice is
so people say well james you're a liar
well yes we deceive the subject in order
to tell the truth to the audience
because it's a question of relative
deception and i argued with eric about
this and he thought weinstein thought
well i could do a little bit of a better
job i could be more efficient i could i
could reduce the harm more and i said i
disagree i think we're i think we're
doing a pretty good job of it and by the
way nobody else is doing it so where's
your control variable
yeah what are you weighing this against
yeah you know yeah so we don't want to
blur faces we want people to see
people's intonation and body language
when we show the the fraud or the lies
hmm
yeah it's tricky i don't know
i don't know if i'm torn or not
i don't think i am especially in regards
to some of these issues like
covet or
you got into voting fraud yeah too right
we should cover that totally but but the
idea of like the ethics behind this i
can see how that could come up it's
interesting
i've definitely thought about that in my
life too whenever i've because my dad is
extremely focused on
truth right yes he's like um tell the
truth or at least don't lie right and so
i got that hammered into me i'd love to
know what he has to say about this
question of ethics and undercover and
i wonder what his position would be i
know
we should set that up we'll set that up
at some point so i'm interested that's a
fascinating issue
it's really fascinating because one
ethicist in this book i i i quoted
someone and he said you can't justify
deception in the abstract
it's like trying to invent dry water or
fireproof coal how do you justify
deceiving someone
in the abstract
it's always this like balancing act this
utilitarian
test
so yeah if you google me if you
wikipedia me if your audience is not
familiar you'll see james o'keefe lies
well okay but
so does cnn and the washington post but
they lie to millions of people
[Music]
i wouldn't characterize it as lying we
present ourselves as something as that
we're not
in order to elicit the truth so that we
can broadcast the truth to the people
yeah
so i had like i said i had um issues
with this i was really sick as a kid and
i can remember when i was trying to
figure out my autoimmunity i i had
doctor's appointments where i'd tell
them what they needed to hear in order
to get the information i needed in order
to continue figuring out what was wrong
with me
and i had absolutely no issues with it
it was like you know some of these
things aren't true i had the same issue
when dad was sick over the last couple
years and was like
sometimes telling people the truth just
doesn't end up with the truth right
but it is complicated very complicated
and there's this whole like again
i'm i'm not a mathematician but
you wrestle with the ethics of it you
have to you have to wrestle with it
you don't like
harming people that's not the point
but if you value
if you put a primary value on people's
right to know information you don't have
a choice but to do it
it's very it's very interesting i think
it's interesting you know i
i think this whole this whole theme of
journalism is interesting in this world
we live in because there's so little of
it there's so little journalism
happening yeah it's crazy when do you
think this switch happened like i had a
question because at some point i mean i
don't know because i don't know when it
was but people used to be you know
anti-government and kind of
anti-authority and journalists were seen
as truth seekers and they're going to
expose
people so i feel like i don't know when
that was maybe the 70s when they were
doing what you're doing but when did
that switch over to whatever we see now
that's a great question
i try to trace it back i think you're
right it's 70s was like the 60s and 70s
to me was just the absolute
um quintessential muckraking journalism
you had the chicago sun times used to do
you think i'm hardcore these guys used
to buy a bar
and they called it the mirage in chicago
and the journalists purchased a bar and
pretended to be bartenders and like
filmed everything and they got they got
shady deals and people doing back room
deals and bribing city inspectors they
had hidden cameras in the rafters
that was hardcore and for like months
you had um i mean you have european
journalists like gunter wallruff who
pretended to be a reporter at the bill
which is germany's largest newspaper
upton sinclair i mean he was the
quintessential american muckraker in
1906 did wrote the jungle he went
undercover but he took off his tie he
had a lunch bucket pail pretending to be
like one of the guys at the meat packing
plant and he wrote about
all of the conditions inside the jungle
something changed i think in the 1980s
and 1990s i think it was
i think it was
litigation was a big big one in 1992
abc news was sued by food lion grocery
food line big grocery store chain abc
news primetime live did a sting
operation where they put hidden cameras
in their wigs and they filmed they were
bleaching the meat they were repackaging
rotten meat eww food lions
stock tanked okay
and abc news got sued
by the grocery store for i don't
remember the exact legal issues but it
was trespass or something like that oh
wow
they won
and abc was one on appeal
but it cost as these things do
millions of dollars
so or over a million dollars so the
commercial imperative
i might actually sound like a socialist
here and i don't mean to i'm just being
honest
the commercial imperative is
incompatible with truth telling
because if your goal is to report on
these things aggressively
well you'll get sued and then you have
to spend all this money defending
yourself in court so what's the easiest
thing to do if you're a capitalist
it's to not do it in the first place
yeah now i'm a non-profit so the profit
is not our uh
uh motive
but abc news stopped doing that was a
shot across the bow for investigative
journalism mike wallace former uh legend
at cbs news he stopped doing ambush
interviews
and over time you had newspapers die out
uh there are no more real newspapers
anymore
as big tech grew in the early 2000s
there was the consolidation of news
and then you had this phenomenon where
journalists became too close to their
sources they don't want to bite the hand
that feeds them
they tend to extol these the virtues of
these people in power rather than to
condemn them
and i and i get it if you're a beat
reporter if you're if you're a new york
times national security reporter and you
got your government sources inside the
nsa yeah what are you gonna do expose
them
you'd be out of a job
and that's what happened
and now it's become and then you had add
this fear thing on to where they'll rage
you and take your [ __ ] if you expose
all these things combined
there's nobody doing it and and of
course the only people who can do it are
independent citizens usually without the
money the resources or the backing
that's what happened
and it's taken about 30 to 40 years for
us to get this far
wow i don't think i've i've really
thought about that before
yeah that's pretty weird because
normally i remember first coming across
your stuff and i thought
well i think first i was like no way
i think that was my first no
you didn't believe it
i don't i think i probably did because
there was you know there were videos i
was like but i was like this is
it's like too good right too good to be
true yeah kind of like like these
stories are you know you go and
investigate some of these what some
people would call conspiracy theories
and then you're proving them and i mean
i like right
i'm with you there so i it was just it
was just surprising it was like this is
a different kind of journalism than i've
than we've seen
and then i remember kind of feeling like
is it appropriate
yeah is it ethical right um and then
being kind of like kind of torn there
but mostly like yeah it's probably
ethical um but then going back to like
60s and 70s it's not even it wasn't even
abnormal right when you thought of a
journalist that's actually what you
thought of and now that doesn't exist
anymore which is crazy yes it is crazy
it is crazy the people in chicago and
chicago sometimes i think uh pam zachman
said that no everyone was afraid of city
hall no one wanted to speak about these
bribes
and if you read a book called the mirage
it's about this bar that they purchased
in 1977 but ben bradley the famous
legendary
executive editor of the washington post
denied the chicago sun times a pulitzer
in 1978
or thereabouts and his rationale was
they used too much deception to get the
story
you have to remember in the early 70s
you had reporters like william gaines
who literally dressed up as a janitor
and assisted in surgery at a chicago he
won the pulitzer prize can you imagine
me
helping someone do surgery and they'd
think that was unethical that's pretty
hardcore
but william gaines exposed the fact that
surgeons were having janitors help them
dissect people what he this is a true
story
no one knows this
he won the pulitzer prize in 1972 the
pulitzer prize
so when they stopped giving out the
trophies for doing undercover work when
they started suing you for doing
undercover work guess what happened
people stop doing it
people stop doing it people don't you
have to be
i'm going to keep plugging the book
because i have to and by the way all
proceeds go to project veritas it's a
great book the first chapter of this
book is called suffering
you kind of have to be a masochist
you kind of have to like pain
to do this
that's not why i do it i don't like pain
and a lot of people will look at the
people that work for me like what's
wrong with you
but we're just passionate
we believe
but yeah it sucks it hurts it's painful
it's a reputational hazard
um
uh but yeah it journalism is is is dying
i don't think it's dead
and again i think it's
i think it requires
normal everyday people honest cops
honest nurses i'm doing a story right
now which i will release next week
involving a massive bombshell
and i can't talk about it specifically
but i told you off the air
and it involves just everyday normal
honest hard-working people who have just
had enough and say hey james give me one
of those hidden cameras
please mail me one of those cameras
because i see this stuff happen in my
input and i just need to record it just
ordinary they don't want to be famous
they don't they don't want to lose their
job
but they've had enough
okay well i i've decided i think that's
reasonable like if you're working a
corporation i can see the need for
privacy
as well
but if you're working in a corporation
that deals with the public too
and things are shady enough that your
employees are like i need a hidden
camera
then maybe
something's up there probably going too
far well how do you define privacy where
do you think that boundary is
i don't think it would be an issue if
people didn't lie
exactly so if you're not like
i can understand where you're coming
from when you can you kind of need to
tell people a story in order to get the
truth out
um but i think in personal lives if
people don't
live a lie
then they probably
don't really have to worry about privacy
i don't know but then it's hard to say
because if government laws change
then
sometimes you're forced to lie in order
to not be in trouble
i don't know to answer are you saying
that people committing malfeasance don't
have any right to privacy is that
effectively what you're saying
no
because i think like i said i think laws
can also change and then you end up
being a criminal
whether or not you want to be this
episode is brought to you by paleo
valley 100 grass-fed beef sticks paleo
valley is a company that is doing great
things for people's health they're
committed to making high quality food
that won't harm you or the environment
their products come from small
family-owned farms right here in the u.s
and their cows are never fed grains or
antibiotics so if you avoid meat for
environmental reasons paleo valley is a
great match
you've probably heard some of the tricks
companies use like claiming their beef
is grass-fed because it at some point
ate grass or american-made meat that's
really only packaged in america if you
guys want a snack that's actually
healthy
this is a fantastic option
i can't eat it because i can't eat
spices because i'm a bubble person but
my brother loves it and scarlet loves it
too you can help your body
and the environment by trying paleo
valley's high quality protein today just
head over to paleovalley.com
and enter code mp for 15 off your first
order that's paleo valley.com with code
mp for 15 off your first order of these
bad boys enjoy the rest of the episode
the privacy issue is a really
i think it's not so much about privacy
because most of these things are filmed
people know that they're being spoken to
they know they're they're sharing
information with a stranger
so it comes down to societal trust
issues why are you sharing this
information with someone you barely know
yeah that's what i said earlier exactly
um and frankly what i've found which is
counterintuitive is that people are more
likely to be honest with complete
strangers think of it taxi cab
confessions the person you met at the
bar the the hair dresser you're more
likely to say the truth to people that
you don't know it's also against your
interest to betray someone it's usually
the person that's
um uh doing that that's violating their
own uh but i think i think it's more to
do with dignity
i think that there's something about
being filmed
you know because think about it i can
write down what you said i can write
about it and you wouldn't necessarily
have a problem with that
but if i film you and you don't know it
and i've been trying to study this
because i can't figure it out why is
recording someone do them more harm than
writing down what they say
and that's a really fascinating subject
i've done a lot of research into this
issue to try to understand it and i've
found that some courts have suggested
that you're violating the person's
dignity you know it's about your right
to control the dissemination of your own
image so this is a really fascinating
thing and as i think we as we grow as as
undercover work uh
these cameras now are so tiny you know
i'm not wearing one right now
but
for the acorn store i put one in my tie
and it was the size of one of these
little icons on my tie
and you couldn't barely see it and maybe
one day you'll they'll make cameras for
your um for your eyeball i kind of have
that image on the front cover of the
book here
um
i don't i don't know maybe they'll put
it in your in a lens like a contact lens
and you're filming everything
so
this is not the government doing this
this is civilians doing this so the law
doesn't apply it's just about ethics
it's about
it's about an ethical question and harm
to people ultimately transparency will
be a good thing for
society
it'll be a very good thing oh yeah and i
think right now it's pretty evident that
we need more transparency
like i think if we go in the direction
of okay
you know there are individuals that
might be harmed from this but there's
more transparency across some of these
institutions i think at the point we're
in that is necessary right that risk is
worth taking well let me give you an
example of
that this is interesting too the
how image compares with the written word
the new york times i keep on picking on
the new york times for a reason
the new york times
um
wrote a story about us
they published our private attorney
client documents i don't know how they
got them
they were obviously stolen or taken
without our consent wow um that means
communication between me and my lawyer
and specifically the lawyer that is
suing the new york times which is in the
united states you can't do that it's a
fundamental law of american
jurisprudence you don't publish the
other litigants attorney-client memos
the new york times did this and the
memos were quite favorable to us the
memos were like we don't break the law
here's how you avoid breaking the law
here's how you behave ethical but the
new york times headline was written in
the following way
documents show
how far
veritas's deceptive reporting practices
could go before running a foul of
federal laws
you know another way of saying that we
check with our lawyers to make sure
everything we did was legal
but do you see how they worded it
yeah yeah you have to kind of like yeah
twist the newspaper to understand what
there's it sounds like i was traipsing
over the boundary
when the memos clearly show so what i'm
trying to say is that
they use words in a mendacious way
they're able to write about you know
that that cup of sparkling water and
make it seem like a cup of coca-cola
but when you film the object it clearly
shows it shows that it's a cup of
sparkling water and that's why i think
what you said is correct the more
things are filmed
the more accountable these people are
going to be and the more free we're
ultimately going to be because they have
a way of with words and i've never seen
it this bad michaela when they wrote
that article i was beside myself
because of course when you write a
headline like that what's the pundits on
twitter going to say yeah there goes
james o'keefe running a foul of those
federal laws well no that's not what the
article said
but they twisted it yeah yeah and i know
you know what i'm talking about because
they do it every day yeah
it's it's maddening
yeah it's just maddening
okay well
i probably need to
you mentioned voting fraud yeah i know
you did a bunch of work into that
okay so
i'm
i'm like
i'm not very familiar because i think
because i'm canadian actually so i kind
of just heard you heard about you're not
an american citizen yet or becoming one
you're canadian slowly slowly yeah never
going back to canada never no things
have to change dramatically before i go
back to canada from toronto yeah toronto
the city or the suburbs or toronto right
downtown yeah they just wrecked it
it's really disappointing yeah i'm like
blaming the government for that one
september i was concerned i thought you
know they're like oh you have 85
vaccination rates we're gonna open back
up and i thought
yeah except you know then there'll be
another variant and there'll be another
outbreak in the winter and they'll shut
everything down again even though
everyone's vaccinated and i'm leaving
before that happens so i left in
september and i like i really left i
threw away my stuff and left really it
must have been hard though because it's
your home
i think i've been through so many like
weird experiences that it wasn't that
hard i'm like a bit upset that toronto
because toronto was a pretty good city
had really cool little areas it was kind
of like new york with well tiny new york
um
and it was cool and now like the
downtown has racked all the cool little
unique stores are closed down right the
neighborhoods i grew up in are in
terrible shape and
like my family the red my family that's
back there my brother and my parents now
are like maybe we need some backup plans
because of the state canada is in so i
don't know if it was scary it was a
little bit scary i guess but
mostly aggravating
i understand completely i'm from new
jersey and our office is in new york
state and i'm still there and i'm
reluctant to leave because it's my home
yeah they're pushing they're pushing it
pretty hard
yeah it's pretty nice in nashville it is
nice i gotta say it's pretty nice here
yeah
okay
voter fraud
was any of that real like i heard um
a lot of people talk about whether or
not that was
our stories are just generally just
speaking
specifically to the reporting we've done
are just speaking broadly about the
election no broadly i'm broadly um
well
and i and i don't know if i can speak
broadly because i don't know enough to
comment i can only talk to what i
witnessed i can only give you anecdotal
evidence okay that stuff that's right i
can give you the anecdotal level yes
in other words things i've caught on
tape that actually did happen yeah but i
that doesn't necessarily mean there was
enough fraud to overturn the election no
okay it just means that fraud happened
specifically i think when people use the
word rigged they mean something
different they mean like sort of this
media
system
you know there's a book by mulling
hemingway called ring she talks about
mark zuckerberg and facebook and their
alliances
i i'll only speak to what i know to be
true in minnesota we did a story
featuring a somali man
named libon muhammad this is in
ward 6 in minneapolis minneapolis is a
very heavy somali community and there
was ballot harvesting what does that
mean they collect other people's ballots
and it is illegal to harvest ballots
what does that mean collect other
people's banks go around and collect
third party but pick them up so someone
comes to your apartment and pick them up
and there was evidence to suggest that
he was filling them out and there's this
one video that he filmed
he filmed himself i did not film him
james o'keefe claims i didn't make these
claims he made these claims he filmed
himself on snapchat
privately but one of the sources came to
me with the recording and liban muhammad
was in his car
covered in absentee ballots and he's
bragging about all the ballots that he's
collecting
hustling at two in the morning
collecting all these ballots and i
report this
because it is a crime
to have more than three ballots in your
possession in the state of minnesota
another video shows a cash exchange for
an absentee ballot to fill it out it's
on videotape you can see both of their
faces they're speaking in somali but we
got a translator this is a federal
felony again
one instance of voter fraud is it i
don't know but
obviously if it happens once it happens
more than once it doesn't mean it's
enough to overturn a national election
but it is my job to report this and i do
september 27 2020 report this video this
video goes wildly viral i mean it's
blockbuster you have a you have a cash
exchange for about caught on tape yeah
the next day
the new york times our friends of the
new york times publish a
a section hit piece and the headline is
experts say
i don't know where they find these
experts experts say project veritas
video was a coordinated disinformation
campaign
the first sentence of the article says a
deceptive video released by james
o'keefe and again there's that word
again deceptive
well the video is not deceptive video
happened
i didn't even film the video it was
filmed by libon muhammad and posted to a
snapchat
but the new york times had interviewed
stanford researchers that's stanford
university california
and got some professor to opine on how i
was a disinformation person
the rationale was i met with mike
lindell the my pillow guy
a couple days prior to show him this
video
and therefore it's disinformation
because i'm coordinating with people but
it's called an embargo in journalism so
they write this article michaela and
then what's up what happens is
absolutely fascinating
the article the new york times comes out
and then of course the new york times is
the holy bible if you will in the tech
world
facebook bans the video
citing the new york times because the
new york times said it's disinformation
and it's this and and then before you
know it people such as yourself or good
citizens out there are thinking yeah
that verita they banned that video for
disinformation that really happened
but it all happened because the new york
times
quoted some expert in california
saying it's different so we sued the new
york times for defamation i said enough
is enough
i was beside myself when this article
came out yeah
i sued them for defamation and just to
give you an idea of how rare it is
for someone who sues the new york times
to win
there's only been
um
i don't know
less than a dozen people in
50 years
to have survived the initial motions in
a lawsuit we survived motion to dismiss
in a defamation lawsuit against the new
york times and the judge in new york
said it was the new york times who
engaged in disinformation and deception
his words and then the new york times
were forced to answer our lawsuit about
this voter fraud video and they admitted
michaela in court that in fact it was
illegal what libon muhammad did they
admitted in the documents he did break
the law but guess what they haven't
corrected the initial article
so we're living in gaga land we're
living in clown world
people say who's going to hold these
people accountable well we did we sued
them we're winning they still haven't
corrected the article
wow so you asked me about voter fraud
and i'm going to give you anecdotal
evidence like i just gave you i can tell
a few more stories like this
i would swear to it under oath that that
was illegal what he did
but
in a world
where the video is taken down off of
these platforms
because it's
disinformation because credible
journalists
say so
by virtue of their own decree that they
are indeed credible because they're
credible
how do you disprove that how do you
fight that
what do you do what's your recourse how
do you hold them accountable
um
i think we're getting farther than any
other organization has i think we are
winning
we're beating them in court
but to some extent these people think
they're above the law
they think that nothing can hold them
accountable so that that's one such
story i could tell more but that will
give you an insight into how
how it is i don't think there was enough
uh you know
and moss fraud but there certainly was
anecdotal fraud
okay that makes sense
it makes sense
okay
we talked about
fauci a bit
but i feel like we should cover that a
little bit more and then wrap this up
all right
um
why is it
that you think
like why is fauci still a good guy in
the mainstream news
like if if what you've uncovered
is true then
how is it that the narrative how is it
that that's not widespread and why that
was a lot of questions there
so good luck with that
um
natalie you may have stumped me on this
one i mean i think this speaks to the
heart of
everything we've been talking about i
just like i don't i don't understand
what's going on at this point
like people think fauci is a good guy
despite the evidence shows that he for
example has lied or
why do people yeah and if what you're if
what you've uncovered is true if that's
true
then why is there what looks like this
giant conspiracy
i think that's a psychological question
i think it's people believe what they is
easiest for them to believe it's it it's
it's tough to have their minds changed
you know we live in a world where people
want to watch cnn and
i'm picking on these organizations
because it's it's laughable it's it's
disgraceful at this point what they put
on tv but why do people watch it why do
people want to believe the chiron's
unseen and because it's easy for them
convenient for them when you shatter
that narrative when you show them the
reality they don't want to look at it
they don't want to believe it that's a
psychological i'm not qualified to
answer that i don't i'm a journalist i'm
not a psychologist
but i can tell you
with a hundred percent certainty that
those documents inside the pentagon are
real
we've we the marine corps major we got
reached out to him for comment he did
tell us that there are other people
inside the government that are good
people that are trying to reform from
the inside we give us another source we
have multiple sources back them up
so i can tell you with 100 certainty
that these things are real
why don't people want to believe it well
i i think
to some extent we are changing people's
minds not to everyone's mind
and i would and i would uh push back on
the notion that everyone still or the
majority people like faushi
there might be a small fraction of
people that do
and you're just hearing more of it
because
there's an unequal representation on tv
and i think we're making a difference
you just can't change everyone's mind at
the same time it takes a little while
okay that's fair i suppose also when you
stop believing in some of these
narratives then and i think this has
happened to me is then you end up
questioning questioning everything right
it's like okay if one thing that you
firmly believed in even if that's like
legacy media or something if that's not
what you think it is then what else do
you know
isn't true right right like what else do
you believe in that's a complete lie and
then that's painful right going through
that it sounds like you went through
that
and then earlier i don't know if you
when it even went through it were you
just always like that yeah it was like
this weird
trait that i had when i was a kid i
don't know i remember i was obsessed
with the media as a young man and my mom
was like
why are you always
bitching about local news and i it was
just bizarre i i did not think i was
going to go into journalism i didn't
know even what what that even means to
go into journalism i just
would watch the local news and say well
that's not the way it is i would be so
weird i would read the new york times i
would say this is not the way it is and
it was the contempt it was the righteous
indignation it was the real it was the
realization that how things were
portrayed
were different than how things are
and things are not as they seem
and that motivated me i didn't know what
to do i knew that it was wrong
i'm not a psychologist i don't know
maybe people are uncomfortable
like you say to change people believe
what they want to believe
but i have seen people change their mind
i saw a law professor after our new
hampshire expose showing dead people
voting he actually changed his mind i
have the email he said i never thought
in person
voter fraud was possible until i saw
your video
and sometimes even if one person changes
their mind it's still worth doing
i'm not a pollster i don't know how many
people but you know people been arrested
raquel rodriguez was arrested in texas
after we exposed her
uh you know involved in selling votes
and buying votes she was arrested by the
attorney general of texas what last year
none of this was reported in the media
of course yeah
still trended on twitter
they took it down but it trended
they can keep taking it down but
we just got to do more of it you know
so wow
okay
well james
that was wild
that was wild
i'm going to link this this is going to
be linkedin show notes and on youtube
and everything it's worth checking out
this is real journalism thank you thank
you very much
for coming and talking to me that was
fun thank you yeah everyone
i'm gonna make a shameless book plug uh
american muckraker
we're a non-profit organization uh and
if you buy the book all proceeds go to
project veritas we're a 51c3
and um stay tuned for i don't know when
you're putting this out but as at the
time of this filming
next week we have a
another coveted follow-up story and this
one is
going to be that's going to be crazy
involving children 5 years old to 11
years old things that happened to them
with this vaccine this is crazy
but it's real
it's true where do people go online if
they want to follow you
um we're still on instagram
barely you can't tag us
which is kind of it's damaging because
the most people will follow you by
virtue of other people yeah
we're on telegram we have 700 000
followers on telegram and we upload the
clips into a telegram you can go follow
project veritas
and people will upload those women
eclipse into their instagrams and into
their twitter wow we call it
distribution by proxy
and it's working effectively
and you could sign up on our email list
and follow us on instagram project
veritas and
americanmuckraker is the book we're also
having michaela and i'm inviting you on
the air a book party a book launch party
in miami on january 29th
you can get tickets to that
projectveritasexperience.com
and uh again all proceeds go to project
veritas okay well thanks james thank you
[Music]
you